[Music]
the future of competitive sailing is
here in New York this weekend
last night's adrenaline-pumping race
took place on the Hudson River with the
boat representing Australia in first
place
Jamie wax is at Liberty Landing marina
on New York Harbor with a look at what
could be the next big thing in sports
Jamie good morning good morning Dana
that's right you see behind me they're
making repairs to great Brittany's boat
that is the boat that capsized yesterday
boat racing is a sport that goes back
thousands of years but never before has
anyone achieved the speeds technology
and equal footing displayed by this
brand-new competitive series the Sal you
here is the signal of the arrival of new
International sailing League sailed GP
taking the time-honored tradition of
racing on the water to a whole new level
the league is the brainchild of
billionaire Oracle founder Larry Ellison
and sailing legend sir Russell Coutts I
had been thinking about this for years
and years and years but so had Larry and
then he just came straight in
we should really you know develop this
new series that you know really runs it
as a proper professional sport that has
the consistency needed to really grow it
to the extent we think it can they
wanted a league that improved on the
sport they loved we used to sit around
and look at other sports and say oh
there they are that racing on a even
playing field and sailing that until now
that actually amazingly never existed
we have a really simple rule and that is
they have to use the equipment supplied
and they're not allowed to change it
they're not allowed to modify so it's
all about the skill of the athletes the
pair's passion for sailing innovation
and technology resulted in this the f50
catamaran a literal dream boat that
combines natural elements human skill
and cutting-edge tech and data to
achieve the fastest competitive sailing
speeds in history at the moment there
are only six of the state-of-the-art
water crafts in existence we started
with 16th because that's the number of
boats that we could get completed before
the start of season one we've got two
new boats under construction so we're
already expanding a championship for
next season we were at the league's US
debut last month in San Francisco Bay
one of the things that really sets this
league apart is that this is a great
race to watch from the shore that crowd
is getting as good of you in a way as we
are on this chaser boat as opposed to
traditional sailing races that take
place over long periods of time and open
water sail GP races lasts around ten
minutes and consists of multiple laps in
a small bay or Harbor type of courses
mean more dramatic moments like this we
got to experience the thrill of sailing
and f50 firsthand on the busy waters of
the new york harbor this is definitely
the coolest thing I'll ever do in my
life I think it was not the Circle Line
tour when you go and experience it live
it's just another it's a whole nother
level wouldn't you agree it's just just
what
it's a wow factor from New York this
year's championship series goes on to
finish up in England and France but
Russell Coutts
hopes the league itself will go much
farther than that you definitely don't
have to be somebody that knows about
something to come along to this I think
is going to be special to many people
and they're going to be wowed by the
speed of these boats
that speed he's talking about can top 50
knots or over 60 miles per hour around
there also the GP and sail GP stands for
Grand Prix which in this case means that
one of the six international teams will
walk on shore at the end of the season
with a million dollars in prize money
love it Jamie adds a little more
excitement
yes different thing it makes it more of
a spectator right exactly and you know
what can I sign up
I wonder if Dan I think we've been
offered an opportunity to get on this
afternoon you should do it yeah
[Music]